citizens I don't know nikoi style
citizens
citizenship Nation we are going to
continue the Kung Fu Panda Journey with
Kung Fu Panda part dose today koi how
you feeling excited for Warfare and
Panda High drinks I have no idea what
this plot's gonna be I imagine there's
more celebrities in here a lot of people
said we'd like this one the most really
you said two is gonna be our favorite
all right I can't wait to find out if
you guys are correct want to give a
heads up even though we're on top of
Kung Fu Panda 2 at the time of filming
this koi is leaving town I live in the
country for 12 to 14 days so he won't be
back for a while so there's going to be
a delay between Kung Fu Panda 2 and Kung
Fu Panda 3 but don't worry when he's
back it's gonna be one of the first
things that we do cover so please do
subscribe and click that notification
Bell to get notified when that reaction
is up here on the channel and also smash
that like button a click or whatever
that move is called skadoos like button
and as always thank you to everyone who
followed us on our patreon page for all
the movie reactions that we've been
covering again so many thank you guys uh
full interaction watch long as we single
with your own copy of Kung Fu Panda 2
available for super sexy Rejects and
recover a bunch of stuff exclusively
there one last thing I wanted to mention
I wanted to get Coy's reaction to this
the time of this being uploaded I
probably already have my own in-house
but uh real rejects has a brand new
shirt Guardians of the Galaxy inspired
but a little bit more than that koi look
away I'll tell you when I look at screen
hopefully you like this shirt boom koi
check it out oh
look at the cuteness that is so much
bigger I'd Wonder isn't that awesome
space babies of the Galaxy yeah guys so
uh one of great way to Source channels
by checking out some of our merch I
can't wait I buy that shirt I wish I had
that to the premiere
so cute so cute Guardians 4. alrighty
guys Link in the description box pin
comment let's get to it
[Music]
changing the time we did hear Michelle
EOS in this
and there she is the peacocks ruled over
gong men City they brought great joy and
prosperity to the city for they had
invented
fireworks nice but the sun Lord Shen saw
darker power in the fireworks
and fireworks
[Music]
Shen's troubled parents consulted a
soothsayer she foretold he would be
defeated by a warrior of black and white
the young Lord set out to change his
fate but what he did next oh
healed it
[Music]
oh no Shen returned to his parents full
of Pride but in their faces he saw only
Horrors genocide yeah he was banished
from the city forever but Shen swore
Revenge he would return and all of China
would bow at his feet all these
characters keep trying to satisfy their
parents a lot of Parental issues in the
world of Kung Fu Panda so this is gonna
be personal for Poe are we about to fear
a peacock
so
[Music]
Forge the ring I love how metal the
prison's heart and Kung Fu Panda land
find more metal China will be mine
[Music]
oh we're gonna learn how Poe was adopted
by the goose oh we have to stop him
stay focused
I was doing that with his face
[Laughter]
do it
[Music]
[Laughter]
so invested
[Music]
your training has paid off
what's more they spoke in the whole
first movie
Master Shifu what do we got Pirates
vandals of volcano Mountain whatever it
is I will take them down because I am in
a mood
[Laughter]
final teachings
uh flow with the water
that's neat
did you do that inner peace
Bandits approaching the musician's
Village danger tell those musicians to
start playing some action music
Shifu I'll Master inner peace as soon as
I get back no snack stops this time
wait are you serious he could have a
strong stork who could handle his weight
that's a lot of story did Poe lose
weight he looks worse I think he looks
more toned part of stamina yeah
[Music]
oh
hello
get out of the metal leave get out of
the metal they made it clear wings of
Justice
[Music]
awesome
hell yeah hell yeah oh yeah
oh this one's so exciting
[Music]
oh
hell yeah
still so impressive they really do a
great job with that
he's coming thanks mantis cool like a
team
I love this Trope that's amazing
oh yeah
wow what an inventive opening fight
cool
[Applause]
good
Cannonball special
nice Vista Fury
monkey Viper yes yes
bunny
[Music]
oh it's like the bridge
oh
is everyone okay yes
that was an incredible that was so good
that was incredible
[Music]
his mom
oh
okay what happened I think I saw
maybe his Goose dad made it with that
pants that Panda and he's half goose
I had this crazy Vision I think I saw my
mom and me as a baby
oh what's happening he doesn't know I
think it's time I told you something I
should have told you a long time ago the
real secret ingredient
you
might have been kind of adopted I knew
it
how did I get here Dad where did I come
from you came from this it was just
another day at the restaurant time to
make the noodles oh he still has the
crate that's cute with my vegetables had
just been delivered there were cabbages
tune-ups radishes
he's the next one on the shirt baby
panda
brought you inside
you gave you a bath
and again
and try to put some pants on you
foreshadowing and then I made the
decision that would change my life
forever
to make my soup without radish
oh that radishes joke was immaculate
[Music]
hey he's back the badass animals
no no
I love the character designs of this
show
now we've got
please leave my house
I love how Sinister this is I love that
yeah what do you want gong Man City
otherwise out of dread that kill for
nothing what in the Box what's in the
box
yeah it's your parting gift
in that it will part you
wow
cool neat
holy
nothing to Peacock could be this good
you are no match for our Kung Fu I agree
but this is
damn whoa
good point blank Canada right out of the
face another genocide
Chen has created a weapon one that
breathes fire and spits metal the
firework Go destroy this weapon and
bring Lord Shen to Justice wait a second
I mean how can kung fu stop something
that stops kung fu
anything is possible when you have inner
peace you must overcome the
existentialism you're feeling po I think
the people are going to be right if this
is about inner peace I'm the Dragon
Warrior it's kind of my job to save Kung
Fu and if I don't what am I you're my
son oh right
po it's time
goodbye Dad
don't worry Mr ping he'll be back before
you can say noodles I have a father his
name is Ben Parker
noodles oh that's sad I hope he learns
to appreciate him by the end let's go
family is inner peace or let's go Bleak
kill off the dead that's the third one
oh
Nate God the dimensions of the entire
animation are phenomenal I want to see
these storyboards because it's so
atmospheric
mom
honey what are you doing here we
replaced you dear with this lovely
radish
frankly does better Kung Fu
no no no no the Jack Black voicing his
own father
[Music]
it's crazy how the usually a sequel
loses its magic of Wonder pretty fast
but this still maintains a really strong
Deering because you're more invested in
him because you love him yeah it feels
like it's picking up perfectly dinner
he
instead of trying to escalate Stakes
it's just changing them which I like
[Music]
Raging Bull why are you really out here
I just found out that my dad isn't
really my dad your dad the goose
that must have been quite a shock
and this bothers you
we're warriors right nerves of Steel
Souls of platinum so hardcore you don't
feel anything that's not true I don't
have any problems with my dad maybe he
could nominate his head before I was
born
that's why you can't throw a Thurgood
for that line the delivery of a manta's
dad jokes so far
he used to let me play here beside him
promising Sunday this Throne would be
mine do you know who the voices it
sounds like Gary Oldman I have to hear a
little more everything must be exactly
how I envisioned it right and I invested
a little to the left with
there that sounded like Ariel in there
yeah every so often the loud part yeah a
peacock is defeated by a warrior of
black and white nothing it's all
happening you can't avoid your fate
that's impossible it is not impossible
and he knows it I saw a panda a Kung Fu
Warrior it fought like a demon big and
furry
find this Panda and bring him to me one
panda lives that does not make you right
being right makes me right
I hope Michelle yeoh and Jackie Chan
have a Scenic oh that'd be great
oh my God
yikes burn down the city guys
they're oppressing this city corrupt
wolf cops
fun hey hey
[Laughter]
you will need help thank you Brave sheep
but it's too dangerous I can't let you
it's not safe to speak right
there Masters ox and crack they're in
gong men jail
you guys probably get out of the outfit
now yeah I'm starting to stay in the
outfit anymore they probably know
worth it I want that joke
oh what a great shot yes
power great shot Pac-Man dragon now
gotcha
nice work classic the Ferocious master
we're gonna free from those bonds of
Injustice no problem gotta be a key
around here no they wouldn't leave a key
around here
oh good you found it
[Laughter]
he will turn the weapon on the city then
we use a sneak attack we get inside and
then and then you will be stopped
[Music]
by the Unstoppable weapon nothing's
Unstoppable except for me when I'm
stopping you from telling me something's
Unstoppable
[Music]
love like the funky side of this I'm not
letting you stay in this cell I'd like
to see you get me out
like I said you are not getting me out
of the cell
you're mine I'll tell you what's gonna
be yours my fist and your plush cuddly
super Softly
oh
I love the like old school Kung Fu
exploitation vibe there yeah
like the exposition insults
oh
it's like Jackie Chan's project a oh
cool yes it's like the wheelchair race
and Days of Thunder Tom Cruise and
Carrie always
wow
[Music]
oh my goodness
we're gonna chase through the city thank
you Kung Fu Panda I love the teamwork of
all them in this movie and the way they
use their animal skills which
momentum
[Music]
oh great
great
[Laughter]
[Applause]
oh nice
you can chain my body but you will never
change
the water they get caught eight point
acupressure cuffs just like the ones
that held Tai Lung the more you move the
tighter they get these are the best cops
was this made for 3D it feels like some
of the shots feel that way greetings
we meet
[Music]
if anyone should be afraid it's you
don't even
I like his like Jafar Voldemort delivery
he's like in both ability
he can be menacing but also take a joke
at the same time it's hard to ride that
line
good job Gary
[Music]
mjolnir my old enemy
stairs
[Laughter]
God I really have to walk all that
oh
thanks for caring me those last few
flights okay
how do you convince them to care we meet
hey how you doing
hey
laughs
we only heard about master Rhino a few
days ago and we came to avenge him
you've come to avenge no
elves well yeah all the pots and pans
that you stole I'm gonna want those back
I don't know what else did you do
funny oh no that's good really dark who
do you think you are panda who do you
think I am peacock
I hope they release these in the
theaters oh that'd be great I'll
re-watch
[Music]
destroy the weapon yeah
just don't see a sign po don't get
trauma track trigger PTSD
up triggered oh
[Music]
I was like Moses
you just let Shen get away at least we
destroyed the weapon that's true maybe
they have another
oh no they have multiple weapons that
seems no
[Laughter]
oh no
it's dark it's dark I don't like it I
don't like the lighting one minute come
on we need you to focus I got it I got
it
I love this one yeah I've been like just
encapsulated the entire time this is
such a great movie
whoa
[Music]
yes
all right that's what I'm talking about
[Music]
holy
right now the peacock who's that voice I
think it's Seth Rogen also is it yes I
was like I was questioning if they would
do like both Seth Rogen like two people
it's just the grunting sounds it's gonna
be someone super iconic and I'm just
gonna throw good
man these sequences are amazing it's
just so much movement it's like a
Non-Stop ride really keeps going you had
shin
okay he got
oh just open up open up get Inner Peace
by accepting the peacock was there the
last time I saw my parents I have to
know
the hardcore can't understand
what did not expect that
but I can't watch my friend be killed
oh they really gave us what we wanted
with from the last movie which is really
spent time and hang out with the furious
five yeah building relationships like
connecting with them yeah this is how
you sequel the dead exists in the past
and I must tend to the Future
what about now
this is like a Fury Road kind of movie
where it just where's like the stories
and the action and everything booms yeah
yeah but it's like that never loses this
emotion yeah I I just can't get over how
much movement there always is yeah it's
always so much
of the peacock hey
[Music]
she keeps rolling
just to do it
yes I watched as your parents abandoned
you it's a terrible thing I believe it
went
this
it went nothing like that there was no
smolting
[Music]
cool
you looking for me
[Laughter]
I said that too soon didn't I like
Terminator 2 reveal
oh just like when his dad put it on a
cat
put here
let me heal you oh my God he had one
just right there so many cannons
his inner peace has been destroyed it
was great disturbance in the force
Dustin Hoffman's barely in this because
he wanted to show his face more
defended he's like I'm just frankly
knocking into it let me sit in a cave or
something
is it a panda is it a panda
give me what I want
all I'll accept
that's a ram
[Laughter]
also good
yeah like he could make me drink this
[Laughter]
where am I
his original home
[Music]
oh no this is really heavy this is
like really heavy childhood trauma
acceptance loss but he just this memory
of the slaughtered God I foretold that
someone would stand in his way a panda
but I never could have foretold what
came next ah she feels partially
responsible yeah
oh it's his hammer
remember let it flow you must accept
Tai Chi
this is so moving
[Music]
oh
damn that guy's evil
that's an evil man your story may not
have such a happy beginning
but that doesn't make you who you are
taste the rest of your story
who you choose to be
that's a great message
oh
[Music]
this is so touching it's so good it's so
touchy who are you panda I have a father
his name is Ben bark I am Poe
and I'm gonna need a hat
[Laughter]
honestly guys I never thought I'd die
like this I always thought I'd meet a
nice girl and settle down and she'd eat
my head
Lord Shen what about the bridge
oh yeah
you coward
he's got the Hat can he wield like the
water and it's like using a water bender
now yeah
what prepare yourself for a hot
this joke before Shazam did it
by a
it's a good joke
hmm
that's your freedom funky
cut your freedom what's your plan step
one free the five what's step two
honestly I didn't think I'd make it this
far
foreign
there is very persuasive
yeah
I didn't see that coming
red panda
the splits are back
oh whoa what power move what
sort of talking about man
[Music]
[Laughter]
God these perspective shots are great so
cool oh whoa
oh
they did not they wouldn't she's had a
lot of great moments though that's how
it works they wouldn't kill her off she
doesn't feel that she feels did they
look up on IMDb right now
I'm gonna wait
dude wield the water they've been
teasing it make him a water vendor I
think it represents flow but it could
also be a power
or maybe she palmed it
oh rage
oh maybe he could be on fire
he's super saiyan now because in her
peace there is a wielding of elements in
the movie I can't wait for it to come
back to something
I'm like it's a metaphor you're like no
he can wheel water maybe
called out lightning po
let's finish this
okay
oh he's can you think he'll do the iron
Palm thing oh the 20 years of training
is happening now I've been predicting
this movie wrong so much I'm trying to
get this down so funny
try to get it down let me have a moment
oh there it is inner peace Matrix bullet
time wield higher wheel the network
inner peace
that's cooler that's cooler that's
awesome
[Music]
nice
all right great video game level I just
want to hear Jack Black in a booth
no
[Music]
it is
awesome I I scarred you for life scars
heal wounds heal oh yeah what do scars
do they fade I guess
is what you choose to be now then I
choose this
you need the one-on-one fight boss fight
boss fight oh
oh
you chose wrong peacock
peacock chose wrong he accepted his own
fate that was pretty hardcore
[Music]
it seems you have found inner peace
and at such a young age
[Laughter]
is so good
wanted was to meet the Dragon Warrior
when do you think he'll be back
hey I don't know maybe never why doesn't
have to go and save China I know why
oh crates from where he came from I know
who I am
you too
I'm your son oh
I love you Dad
let's both cook
together to get a no alcohol
there's a there's a whole bunch of their
holiday Panda
that's not the end
can you imagine if they never made parts
we think this will do well
oh damn that was beautiful that was
beautiful
oh that is really beautiful
what an exceptional sequel I know holy
like
this vastly surpassed the first one for
me I love the first one and I was
surprised at how much because it had
been so praised but this was like this
was one of the better animated movies
I've ever seen this is he had a whole
other level than me Lucy Liu
wasn't she in the first one
[Laughter]
I think these are all the Warriors five
still uh who's she in there she one of
the five she's uh she doesn't talk a lot
it took evidently
um
the store no
Shelia was new
she was the ram
Danny McBride oh who sounds like Seth
Rogan yeah okay
what
and Jackie Chan
I love how they give him that little
three give him that extra love he should
I wonder if it helps with like China
release oh that'd be interesting and
there's also a nod to like the world
they built yeah
I mean Michelle has been part of like a
bunch of action fantasy as well but she
was new to this one right so like Jackie
Chan yeah I wonder if there's like a
channel a little more lines in the third
film if there's like
Tony jaw or like Jet Li like they add
yeah oh donut shot is Thai if I'm
obviously
they're in Thailand
where are the pandas is that the third
movie I want to know that has to be the
third gotta be right it seems like
essential viewing because I was
literally watching I was like it's like
an hour into this going I don't know how
you would top this with like another one
yeah and there's a fourth
I know that's been a lot of years in
development though which I like that
they're taking their creative
Consultants oh it shines it shows I love
that they're taking their time oh yeah
the character designs some of the dark
Menace yeah the camera work with a lot
of it yeah I think it totally shows uh I
love that they're take they took their
time for a fourth one because you could
you know undermine a franchise this
strong if you just make them you could
Shrek it you could Shrek it and you
gotta come back and Puss in Boots
yourself
yeah because the the movie was so
effective in every corner and I thought
they really improved and it had such a
had such a catharsis to it yeah you know
I like I really enjoyed the first one a
lot
um but this was so much more emotionally
gripping and it's more exciting like it
okay to really lay it out here Master
Croc was John yeah that tracks
got it okay so for me a sequel should go
you know deeper and whether that means
more action like as long as it doesn't
cost you the story like a lot of times
Seekers go out and big I like when
schools go in and like the first movie
you've got to set up so much world that
this is exactly what I want a sequel to
be like they trust the audience to be
invested in the characters so you could
just like get more rich and then like
the character design I loved how cool a
peacock was yeah and then you're
invested already so you can really go
heavy with everything and then the
action is just so visceral and moving in
kinetic that like the Still Moments are
so resonant and the kinetic action is so
much like I could see how a
five-year-old would be just so
stimulated but then you can add like
stuff for adults to be grounding like
this is exactly what I want out of
animated film it was a pure Adventure so
exceptional it was a genuine adventure
with so much Soul throughout it and I
think they've really nailed something
down with Poe here because it's easy to
make him relatable in the first one yeah
and now that he's Dragon Warrior status
it's easy to lose that relatability and
sometimes what movies will do is like
well let's just make him like behave a
little dumb or something like that in
order to maintain that relatability but
they don't rely on that they don't like
they don't Dum him up more or something
along those lines
um he's a bit of a doofus as but that's
the character but he's not incompetent
you know and I like that that's a hard
lot to walk it's a really hard line but
movies often botch that and they manage
to make him even more relatable yeah
even though he's the Dragon Warrior now
I'm like how'd they do that he's the god
amongst men and he's also trauma induced
like he's got so much you attached to
yeah and they honed in on the soul of
every character here more like the
father and some relationship is every a
lot of things that were just kind of
cute or charming in the first one I
think they really found the a much
bigger Nuance to it like with the dad at
the case I'm like damn that is such a
powerful moment at the end too like you
know you you want that ending when he
comes back he's like you're my like I
immediately saw it the second it was
after everyone did when he when he finds
out he's adopted that he'll come back
around and be right here like it's such
an obvious beat but it's about does the
movie earn its journey to getting there
and like you want it to happen to where
it doesn't feel cheap and it doesn't
feel cheap it feels rewarding by the end
I love it so many stories are a certain
path that's how you get to that and like
resulted whether it was worth the
journey and like that Journey was
beautifully told like the the Redemption
moment for their relationship was
amazing and yeah the way they've
elevated their action I I liken it to uh
I don't know it's like the it man like
this we got to do with action right you
always got to up it in some way yeah but
I like how they didn't just do it purely
through choreography like the first
fight they have here it's like you see
his pose part of the team and they keep
that Dynamic throughout but then when
they have like the chase scene going on
wow this is so visually stunning I I
found myself see the first one I was
really enjoying from like
uh I really had fun I was observing it
you know it was really fun this one I
was I I would forget that I'm like
getting transported into it to the point
I'm like oh there's a camera here yeah
at no point did I think I'm watching a
movie Once 20 minutes were in like I I
stayed so like oh my God it was
absorbing it was an absorbing experience
like I love this uh I like this one I
was expecting like from people like
preparing us that would be better
um I always worry I always remember
this was another level to me I'm like
this wasn't I was transported during
this one yeah do I do I like feel as
connected and can I attach when the
expectations are so high and then you
add the SQL element to it and it I think
is one of the better sequels like this
was a really special delivery because
you've got all these characters and I
think the team Dynamic evolving with
action allows you to feel the team
Dynamic evolving with them emotionally
and then you've got all the emotion yeah
love that like what a stunning film I
really appreciate because yes does uh
let's Dustin Hoffman's character
deceiver the red panda the Red fan
but he's there he's fun it's fun to have
him there and I like how that he sets up
the theme of the movie yeah um so that
and then when he comes back around the
end it's great there's also an element
of uh okay good I'll start the post
credit uh they did a thing that I think
a lot of superhero movies try to do
which is at a big Crescendo of action
you're so tense that sometimes a joke
works sometimes it doesn't and there
were like three amazing jokes at the
peak of action that um made it better
not worse like the scars fade was so
good yeah like guy doesn't fade I guess
like that was that would have not worked
with another voice actor a different
delivery like that was so spot on wounds
heal scars then fade fade I guess like
genius it still seems within the
character as opposed to we need to make
it funny to light it up because it's a
kids movie yeah and like some movies do
not get that difference this really got
that and I I like the I like the choice
of the animation for the flashback when
it was more of this like hand-drawn 2D
yeah but then as it becomes this visual
representation when he does accept what
the memory is how it morphs into the
current animation yes I was like oh that
kind of creates a distance and a barrier
for him by keeping him that kind of 2D
animation and then it becomes and
becomes one with it with the current
animation I thought that was like a cool
visual representation and like I I do
feel like that acknowledges trauma in a
really unique way that you you when you
don't accept trauma separate from it so
like you're saying once you absorb it
into you it's it's more like your
day-to-day life which was really
beautifully told yeah it's a great story
about acceptance I mean you see a lot of
stories that deal with grief and whatnot
uh this I thought did it in a very
different way that really was about like
don't let yeah a lot of themes like
don't let the past Define you you know
and move forward but what matters is
what you do today and like there's a lot
of themes in the last one about presence
so they carry the themes on but in a way
that feels organic yeah and not just
like we need a new movie to do right
right
I guess we should it made a lot of money
DreamWorks having their own Styles also
really lovely I mean Pixar's got that
existential thing down but these ones
have that action adventure plus
morals oh well they gave us the the papa
bear
I feel like that would have been a
problem it would have been the
post-credit but it also didn't feel like
a post-credit no it felt like it was
where it belonged but I imagine that
like if there had been one Boop I mean
they must have known that this was gonna
be like a massive hit I mean yeah what
if I cannot believe it's a 7.2 in IMDb
those Cowarts
um that was excessive really have less
of a rating it is yeah this was it it's
also lowering on tomatoes I feel like
um Kung Fu what yeah how I don't know it
said 91 the other 96 if I remember
correctly what right I could be wrong
but I remember looking and thinking two
was lower which doesn't make sense this
is
so like I thought this was great and
perfect I thought this was Superior by a
lot and I love the first one but I get
the first one like a B plus a minus
border and I give this one a full a like
this is a comfortable a film to me I I
yeah I thought this was excellent and
the villain was great the
I like how the villain mirrored I mean
they do such a good job with both of
these movies with the villains of them
mirroring some type of Journey that
parallels our protagonist characters
right but the way they did it with him
of of tying it into something that was
it was dark that was dark that is
like
not you know
that is a really hard line to ride
because it's like a slaughtering right I
mean you find out they're not dead so
probably like a little bit but not until
the last five percent of the movie it's
really at the end of the movie I'm like
damn these guys
like it was really heavy for a while
yeah yeah that is a dark ass scene and
the paralleling of like whether those
traumas shape you into good or evil I
loved like him lose his parents like
what you're saying is those those
villains do that and I'm really curious
what the third one does but also the
fact that it doesn't feel like sometimes
the villain problem in movies is okay
they're boring because they do the exact
thing in the opposite way yeah like like
the uh for me a big example is a yellow
jacket in ant and two or Ant-Man one
sorry Warriors was like okay I get it
villainy when you have science and power
right they could have very easily made
him like okay he's a bad guy because he
lost his parents he's good guys he lost
his parents and at no point did I feel
like the Gary Oldman take was
um lacking the depth of pain or
Justified like he felt completely
justified in his mustache twirling and
they gave him a mustache it's amazing
they can get actors like Ian McShane and
Gary Oldman to play these characters and
you really get the sense that they truly
let them bring something to it because
it's such it's so easy to just write off
like they're just villain characters but
especially with they gave Gary Oldman to
do here yeah I love that he was able to
weave in and out of being menacing but
also being someone you laugh at and he
like knew when like even that line
delivery of my favorite line deliveries
this most simple one when the when Poe
says Hey react to it he's like upset and
uncomfortable
yeah like I don't know how to proceed
with this it was such a well done line
and I think Gary Oldman is is a great
casting because he's someone who you
imagine is being a very serious guy yeah
um and but he's got such versatility
when I John and I we saw The Simpsons
movie John and I together and Gary
Oldman was in our row yeah uh years just
had like a regular screening at
Universal it was with his family and he
was like cracking up during the movie
and like stomping his feet and it compli
and he had his uh Gordon mustache on it
oh that's great he must have been like
in the middle of film and reproduction
or post-production or some right um
better set it up but he had to see Gary
Oldman who you know is like this super
serious guy just enjoy it yeah like
laughing at The Simpsons Movie I'm like
it painted him in a whole different
light to me like oh yeah you got to be a
bit of a goofball to do the kind of
that Gary Oldman does yeah would you go
from everyone into like the chaos of
Gary Oldman yeah yeah uh so I thought he
was great uh he was excellent of course
again the the evolution of the animation
with uh you know the
weaving in the I don't know the feather
reaction with the peacock I don't know
words yeah the visuals of the four I
always talk about the the fourth
dimension I love the z-axis I love when
it brings it out to you sorry third
image when it comes to you I think is so
well done here and then blending that
with the flow State the slo-mo and all
those elements that felt so
photorealistic at points like I was
watching a panda Bend Water and I was
like I feel like I'm watching a like a
documentary like it felt so photo real
in those close-ups is there stop motion
a motion capture apply to any of this I
don't think so sometimes they do that
like in the final episodes of The Clone
Wars they had a fight with Darth Maul
and they they actually made it uh I mean
everything it was it was always animated
and then for that one they made it um
motion capture I know with Rango they
had the actors actually like which is
why I think that movie is so visually
unique so they get an actual snake to do
something do you think the panda
I love the third Act of the movie we're
like is he gonna is he gonna maybe I was
trying to just predict something
I don't know the obvious like I'm gonna
come around to you Dad but
give me some surprise I love that it
subverted your expectations that you
kept throwing at it I thought he would
wield fire or something that was so good
that was such an a film like that is so
comfortably I'm surprised that it's got
a lower I'm 90 what what is what is the
rating let's find out okay Rotten
Tomatoes and I don't want to know who's
in the third one so I'm gonna be very
careful not yeah I've enjoyed this
because I had a slight bit of
familiarity with the first one but um I
had no familiarity wait let me know when
how recent the third one is because this
came out in 2011 according to the
credits okay Kung Fu Panda uh okay the
first one
wait there's a show positives okay I
don't know I'm gonna type in two uh 2011
81 oh wow that is low for what that just
was what is the consensus
um
storyline Arc may seem a tad familiar to
fans of the original it is so different
from the original Tad familiar there is
so little to do with the first one like
he literally goes on a completely
separate Arc what are they talking about
he leaves home like there's nothing in
the first one in this
the opening is different like it's a
continuation but if you want them to be
like different characters
that consensus is what's okay
I'm gonna try Okay so that's 81 for the
for the new one uh the first one got a
yeah don't look up I'm trying to not
touch anything don't look up three
literally don't three the reason eight
yeah okay I'm literally like hiding half
my phone so I can just see the date go
scroll click the time 87 87 oh okay it's
not that far off six percent but it's
better yeah no it is better I'm
surprised but like 87's approaching an A
and that was like a low B that's
shenanigans
I don't know what people say position
maybe 19 lack of Dustin Hoffman
that's it the red panda was ended up but
19 of critics like however many vote I
don't know I don't want to read too much
but like 19 thinking it's less than a
three that's silly we must get more
Tigress backstory in the in the next one
yeah I mean you see a little bit of it
of how she wanted to appease red panda
[Music]
but we don't but we did this one really
hints a lot more that's another thing
it's Angelina Jolie they actually like
let her be a freaking character this
time yeah this one I actually felt like
they utilized her voices
they were trying like let's give him
like a couple of lines to cut into yeah
Michelle Yo's lines in here equal more
than Jackie Chan's lines in both this
one and the last 100 guaranteed I don't
know why I think uh they leaned into the
Rogan Comedy perfectly too the Mantis
jokes were so good for me like I really
love those yeah I feel like they finally
found that like mix of we have these
actors we've established them we have
these characters and now we let the
actors do the thing we have higher than
four more here
um I thought this was a brilliant
brilliant sequel uh I loved it I would
give it me personally I did this like a
99 yeah I thought I I don't know it was
like 95 96 for me what do you not if you
had to find something to pinpoint that
you didn't like
honestly the little short
uh and my biggest flaws I wanted more of
it well there was times that I was like
okay I'd love to see a little bit more
of this element this element but not in
a bad way that's going to drop it from
an A to an even an A minus but like for
me there's no such thing as perfect I've
only given 20 movies five stars so it's
just like that is an element I like
Jimmy and I've only ever seen I think
there's literally 20 movies I consider
perfect well
he says that's weird because I feel
opposite I I feel like this felt longer
than 90 minutes but in a complimentary
way oh interesting yeah see like I
wanted to live in the first act a little
bit more and like reacquaint myself with
everybody because if I feel like if I
hadn't seen the first one a week ago if
I'd seen it like four years ago like
everybody else I'd want to be a little
bit more in the in the fun zone of like
remember your friends oh really you know
what I mean oh I mean that's weird wish
but we didn't watch the first one I won
but yeah but I'm watching it with the
eyes of someone that like imagined just
watch it with your horizon your
experience but like you've got to know
when it came out in response to the
first one
I would just watch them I was like I
watched but that's kind of like the
issue that I think some people running
with guardians three yeah is like I
because I watched all the movies in one
week it like literally watch holiday
special next finished holiday special
the next day went into Guardians three I
was like oh this is perfect yeah you
know but then there's a lot of people
who are like oh I want more Groot I'm
like but you got plenty yeah
oh yeah yeah I mean I'm gonna re-watch
them from my re-watch but I didn't have
time for my first watch so I'm actually
curious how that affects it yeah but I
will acknowledge that like I've most
people are gonna have watched it in the
last week oh of course yeah no a
thousand percent you're right I mean who
knows over the years because people
probably also binge I also wish we had
time for three before I left I was like
damn we should just do three yeah
because like that was exceptional that
was that was amazing
um but no I think it'd be good to get
some distance then we could actually see
it through the lens of not having seated
back tomorrow so it's like a 10-year Gap
isn't it isn't it or like this who says
seven yeah it hasn't even been 10 years
uh since uh wait no it's been 12 in real
life
uh no I thought it came out I don't know
I've never even seen a trailer for it I
assume it was in the in the late teens
because of the um I thought it was like
2015 or something oh then maybe they did
like a one-two punch because the ending
like because of the panda and I think I
would have to come out a little closer
maybe they have the t's yeah maybe that
already like started work on it like
Lord of the Rings
yeah I don't know I love how little we
know about all of this I was like hiding
the dates on my photos Rotten Tomatoes
because I like that might give context
of who the bad guy is like what actor's
gonna be the best other than Kung Fu
Panda 4. next year yeah they said 2024.
okay cool
we'll do an out of the theater reaction
in a year this is where I try to
convince koi to skip the theater
to do reaction together here do you
think they'll do it in like a 45 day
window or do you think that'll be dead
by then well actually funny enough I
mean I was so close Mario at the time of
filming this Mario comes out on VOD next
week yeah and I was like oh I want AMC
still playing an IMAX but then I
realized oh wait right now but then
guardian's gonna push it out and then a
couple days later after Guardians comes
out then Mario goes on video 100 that is
all part of the plan so I'm like maybe
we'll get okay I skipped 65 so I could
watch it on the number one hit of the
summer
we're going on this journey quantity
it's going to be a year of me trying to
convince koi it's probably gonna be I
mean it might succeed I love the theater
experience but this has been really fun
doing these with you so maybe out of
honoring the scenes the honoring it's
gonna be like my battle between loving
exhibition and the series that you've if
you want to be watching Kung Fu Panda 4
if you weren't watching one two three
over here that's true
all right well join him in uh in that
quest to get me to skip at the after the
release yeah a thing I don't do we'll
see we'll see maybe I might change my
mind
all right guys well thank you so much
for being here thank you I hope you have
fun and wrong I hope you're having fun
right now right while you're there
um hey guys leave a like subscribe keep
a lookout for Kung Fu Panda 3 we'll try
to get it to you within the month at
least and please take some time to put
together people and uh yeah go get
yourself a space baby shirt too
peace
very very soon but let's end this with
the
Chase Gardener Chase my friend thank you
so much for being here
um we're gonna do a special kind of
shout out because we saw that you
commented on our watch Along on patreon
and you are one of our patrons who
qualifies for us a special dedicated
shout outs we're gonna answer a question
oh I like it Chase is asking have you
guys seen How to Train Your Dragon
Trilogy series highly recommend after
you watch these movies love Kung Fu
Panda well koi I you actually koi gave
me an answer about this before we
started Kung Fu padness so take it away
koi I consider How to Train Your Dragon
one of the only perfect trilogies I
think uh that should be in conversation
with Back to the Future with Lord of the
Rings with the Before Sunrise Trilogy
How to Train Your Dragon I think all of
them are Immaculate and uh I honestly
it's one of the most emotionally
investing series I've ever experienced I
truly love that series and uh was lucky
enough to go to the premiere of the
third one and tell everyone that made
any of them how much I loved it it was
really funny to see uh animators get
their like their do love and that whole
team's wonderful well my answer is oh
it says Greg answer uh I was on you know
a certain kind of Gregory how do you and
gummies for many years a period of time
there's like a solid like eight years in
my life and I saw one definitely like
that all I remember is one scene where
toothless of being like hey even like a
cat and then I saw another and then in
part two
I'm pretty sure I saw that in the
theaters but I don't remember it's such
a blur it feels like a nightmare to me
and three just came out too and I I saw
three
I honestly have no wow what the plot is
I can't it's the second one does
something to do with the mom right yeah
and they find out she's alive yeah
that's what I remember remember feeling
like a nightmare scene and the dad dies
yep and then the third one sorry if I
spoiled How to Train Your Dragon for you
but that that's all I remember is being
in the theater just the emotional
totally on something and being like this
is like a nightmare
you gotta re-watch those but then uh
yeah so that's the thing I can't I can't
watch it here because I remember that
plot Point too well uh even though I
don't remember anything else surrounding
that one scene he'll be talking about
this team well I remember this how do we
get to that everyone see the three yeah
I can't remember for the something to do
with a pirate was it a pirate so
basically the dragon Kingdom has been
destroyed and then they find out there's
other Dragon kingdoms and there's a
piratey-like villain yeah
you should watch them they're really
good they're so good I don't remember
um
thank you I was able to say J Bar Raquel
every time I'm just like Jay yeah uh
between Hiccup and him and I love the
parallel of like they're wounding I love
that like the costumes evolve and like
it's one of the few animated series that
I can think of where like a thing will
happen to damage a character and they'll
use that as either a plot point or like
a visual reference in the next one so
like scars impact things and clothing
evolves and all the relationships
between like the Viking warriors are
cool and like Gerard Butler's it's so
good it's so good and Jay barkel so
slept on as a voice actor he's
Immaculate well Chase we gave you an
answer that you probably could have been
like yeah we've seen it but we we went
for it we went for it just to give you a
detailed answer there Chase thanks so
much for being here buddy and showing
your support we'll talk with you all
soon
[Music]
thank you